police in Northern California may be
closer to learning who allegedly
kidnapped a mother while she was jogging
sherry Pappy nee vanished last November
she was found three weeks later bruised
and beaten but alive
the peeny helped investigators creat
these two sketches of the hispanic woman
that she says abducted her Anna Werner
is here with newly released details in
the case and a good morning good morning
almost one year ago sherry Pappy knee
was found beaten and shackled on the
side of a California freeway now
investigators hope these sketches may
finally help them get some answers about
how she got there
last November police got a frantic 911
sherry Pappy knees husband Keith who
said he found her phone about a mile
from their Shasta California home I
found her phone it's got like hair
ripped out of it like in the headphones
so I'm like totally freaking out
thinking like somebody like what's her
grabbed her three weeks later on
Thanksgiving Day 2016
she was found bruised and tied up with a
chain along Interstate five poppy knee
was emaciated weighing just 87 pounds
and had a brand burned into her shoulder
she was bound with restraints but was
able to summon help from a passing
motorist who then notified law
enforcement poppy knee told police how
two women with their faces covered held
her at gunpoint and pulled her into
their vehicle but investigators found
both male and female DNA on Poppy knees
body and clothing belonging to neither
Pappy knee nor her husband
poppy knee said her abductors spoke
Spanish most of the time she was in
their custody but struggled to give
officers more sherry did her best that
she could in providing the descriptions
but was not able to provide a detailed
description do the suspects covering
their faces
what mystifies investigators hear is
there's no clear motive officers say
poppy knee had been texting with a male
acquaintance from Michigan who she
planned to meet with but police spoke to
him and have cleared him of any
involvement
Noora unusual story indeed Ana thank you
so much